[Music]
as we wind down on the year i'd like to
give a shout out to such an awesome four
season that we've had it's a season that
has no shortage of drama and action and
as we start looking at the season in
retrospect i'd love to share some of my
favorite fights from the season so i
hate to keep you waiting let's jump in
and enjoy some of the best anime battles
fall 2021 had to offer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we start with jolene and jotaro versus
john gallier for long time jojo fans
this is one of the more anticipated
fights in stone ocean after a long
absence from direct action giorgiaro is
finally back and he's on a mission
unfortunately his and jolene's escape
attempt ends up being a trap set by john
gallier hence we get this fight it's
pretty much what you'd expect from a
jojo fight with all the insane powers
but with the added emotional investment
of a fractured family coming together to
fight among the fights in stone ocean so
far i find this quite cool in a way
because it also feels like some torch
passing ceremony in the form of a fight
granted jotaro didn't die but the fight
feels like him finally passing the
reigns to his daughter now i don't want
to spoil his fate after this but this
fight is the perfect setup for that
crowning moment david production did
this fight justice and i'm so glad they
pulled it off the good news we're just
getting started part six is full of
these wild fights i can't wait to see
animated it's gonna be so hype when we
get there
i'd say one of the most personally
impactful fights this season had to come
from tact of destiny yep i'm talking
about lenny and titan's last stand
tacked up destiny has been one of the
surprise bangers this season is due to
fights like this we're used to seeing
some wide-scale destruction from the
show but how about this last fight that
lenny and titan had together it's just
fast-paced insanity and that's to be
expected considering the guys behind
tact destiny the action's furious the
moments are tense but those are barely
the main reasons why i find this fight
so good what i like the most about the
fight is the consequences of it both in
universe and to us viewers who had to
lay witness to such an emotional moment
yeah i know the fight had death flags
plastered all over it but has that ever
diminished the impact of a fight like
this for you i mean personally speaking
not much the fight may have been lenny
swansong but he'll always be remembered
such a great supporting character that
gave off a comforting aura this has been
an emotional end to his tale and the
feels came from a show that i didn't
expect them to come from
now given the premise of the show it's
obvious that we'll be getting at least
one awesome strategic fight from
platinum end battle royale anime with
supernatural beings has always been a
recipe for some cool combat and for
platinum and it holds up its side of the
bargain this is a fight that featured
quite a hefty use of cg now that doesn't
make it any less good as i still got my
heart pounding with how fast everything
moved it's quite hard to follow the
actual action but that only adds to the
moment with how wildly the camera angles
were you can really feel the intensity
of this showdown platinum end prides
itself on its premise of pitting world
views against each other both sides have
different viewpoints on killing people
and that puts some added stakes in this
already nice fight now what i want to
say that platinum end is a candidate for
anime of the season it's got some very
intriguing themes alongside the deeply
passionate fights
[Music]
[Music]
one piece stays strong with this next
fight luffy and x-drake versus numbers i
really like how one piece is so
seamlessly adapted to modern anime
techniques it's not a show with fights
as mind-blowing as ufo table or mapa
ones but they are still damn good we've
had that zorro moment not too long ago
and now we have this let's just say that
this pose animation for the series has
been insane the fight itself is simple
to be honest it's luffy showing how
strong he's becoming my destroying
opponents bigger than he is still let's
appreciate the effort that got put into
it you can really feel the impact of
each earth shattering attack the way the
whole thing gets presented and it caps
off with a key moment of drake asking to
join luffy's alliance now if a simple
fight like this got this amount of care
from the anime team imagine the latter
fights down the line tam i'm so excited
just thinking about them
if you've been watching my videos you
know that i've said a lot of good stuff
about dragon quest it's quite the niche
anime but i really like the nostalgic
feel it gives me it's also got some
nifty fights that 19 shonen fans would
like well what do you know dragon quest
does it again most notable in the fight
is how dye just parries every explosive
like it's nothing not quite ichigo
slashing away sembon zakura level but
it's still cool seeing the scene in
anime form the fight's quite standard
but i think it's the voice acting and
then the camera angles that make this
fight so good simply beautiful work in
presenting this fight it's very
impactful and attention-grabbing and
that finishing blow is just a thing of
beauty it's as shonen as it can be and
fans of the genre will definitely love
this fight now let's take a break then
shall we do you know what makes video
creators happy subscriptions so if you
haven't done so yet please make sure to
hit that subscribe button and get those
numbers up a million subs somewhere in
the middle of next year is the goal come
on let's do it together
versus hounds deserves a special mention
i'm not gonna lie here i almost
overlooked ranking of kings at the start
the simplistic art didn't appeal too
much and the premise didn't seem that
interesting to me to be honest but to my
surprise it ended up being one of the
best anime this season as i said in a
previous video that you can check out
another surprise came in the form of a
fight that i didn't see coming dorche
fighting beasts may not seem too
impressive in terms of its premise but
i'll just let the actual anime clip do
most of the talking i mean just look at
the level of detail there this is truly
some impressive battle animation and
you've got to give props to the studio
for making the fight so beautiful i mean
what am i saying it's wit we're talking
about here ranking of kings may not be
some battle anime where hype fights
abound when it comes to confrontations
like this the show doesn't disappoint
thanks to the level of detail and the
stakes that you can feel
sparky's always prided itself on those
insane fights that show off the
grittiness and the violence that people
have loved martial arts anime for bucky
continues to impress in his latest
season with this battle that pits our
main character against oliver now this
fight has what we've always loved about
barky the sheer unadulterated
over-the-top violence and intensity that
comes with every battle the insanity is
just off the charts with this battle and
both fighters do their share of flexing
on the others in a show of power this is
the fight where you can truly feel the
pressure and impact with each blow
connecting and that kind of presentation
really adds to the fight if you're up
for some good old smash mouth fighting
featuring monsters of men this could be
a good entry point for getting you to
start watching bucky
we never got a choji versus sasuke
fighting the original series but here we
are lots of good things can be said in
this showdown between best friends
sarada and chocho duking out already had
some emotional investment behind it the
actual fight is as cool as it gets
splitting hand-to-hand face-offs and the
unleashing of some old favorites makes
this great fan service for all-time fans
on a side note you can already see some
of the ujiha ruthlessness seeping
through in this fight even if she's
fighting her friend she'll be a
powerhouse when she's older but only
time will tell how destructive that
power can be remember karkashi's quote
about chidori yeah considering she
attempted the move on her friend i'd say
there's room for interesting
developments ahead
i honestly didn't expect the second
season of demon slayer to recap morgan
train in its first episode but the
moment that announcement was made one
thing became clear those of us who never
saw the movie in theaters would get the
chance to see one of the most hyped
fights of the past year in rengoku vs
akaza and knowing ufo table you know
they're already gonna do a damn good job
on it and let's just say i was simply
blown away how the fight translated into
the anime format it's got a lot of the
stuff we've come to love from demon
slayer fights like the special effects
the awesome animation and the intense
music and voice acting
you know it's been a long time coming
mushoku tensei has had some good fights
but i think that every major isekai
needs to have that big fight the one
with a lot of oomph that people will
always remember enter dragon god orsted
the battle waste no time getting to the
good parts kicking off with an intense
barrage that's all sorts of awesome if
you've still got doubts on how much care
is given to animating mushoku tensei
this fight should erase the last of
those doubts the others then get
involved in the fight but alstead
disposes of them all without breaking a
sweat overall the buildup of the tension
the sound direction and the post fight
repercussions make this battle so
awesome it's a squash match that looks
so unexpectedly cool but i personally
felt bad for how badly dead end got
destroyed i won't say i cried at the
scene but seeing the defeated dead end
gave me some of the strongest emotions i
felt this season so that's my list but
what about yours are there any other
fights that you really enjoyed from the
fall season come share with everyone on
the comment section if you can't get
enough of these lists and want more
check out the rest of my channel i've
got seasonal stuff decade stuff or just
lists that talk about certain moments
like villains showing their power and
flexing on the heroes all the times
heroes get betrayed and come back
stronger you can support the channel
through both my patreon and channel
memberships the links are down below you
might also want to drop by and give my
instagram a follow so that you'll get
the latest news and know what's going on
both in the world of anime and this
channel i had fun making this video and
i hope you had a good time watching it i
hope to see you again for the next video
and i wish you a great day